[Music]
[Applause]
this guy would know better than me Ian
Rapaport NFL Network National Insider by
the way Dolphins Chiefs Saturday at 8
Eastern exclusively on peacock Ian let
me start with the Patriots what do you
think this comes down to for Robert
Craft Andor bill
bellich I mean I would say the simplest
way to say it is is I think it came down
comes down to what's the best for the
organization right because we're all I
think this thing has kind of gone a
couple different ways I think midseason
probably after Germany people were kind
of like yeah you know I guess Bill will
probably be out and it's like okay and
yeah maybe and then you watch this team
really really close and they are not
that talented I mean they're really not
they are not like one of the bottom
rosters in the NFL they played really
hard they played really tough they lost
a lot of football games and they looked
like a team that continued to play for
their head coach what that means I do
not know and I think belich kind of made
it clear in his postseason presser like
he is not quitting he wants to be back
he is under contract um if he is going
to be gone they are going to have to
fire him I was told that Robert Craft
does not want to fire him so I don't
know if these two men will get together
and say Here's the best path forward I
also would say this if belich is going
to leave let's say not get fir but let's
say it's at some point they get to
Mutual parting I believe it will be with
a place where he knows that he has
wanted so I know everyone wants a quick
solution and as someone who spends a lot
of time covering these things I also
would like a quick solution um I don't
know that it's going to be quick at all
because there's so many moving parts and
like you know the the Titans took two
days to to deal with Mike Vel situation
and he had been there six years belich
has been there for two decades this
might take a minute but how surprising
is the Vel F firing and what what does
that mean for the coaching searches for
for teams after hearing that news
yesterday yeah I would say um pretty
significant and I wasn't totally
surprised you know you could sort of
sense and my good buddy Tom pelis an
article on this kind of right at the end
of the season something was not right I
mean all the rumors came out you know
he's sitting next to the crafts in a box
he's there for the Patriots Hall of Fame
induction and then he and all these
rumors come out and then he comes back
and like no one addresses anything and I
think inside the building I'm not
talking about general manager Rand
carthon I thought the relationship was
fine like good fine workable fine um he
never from my understanding brael never
stepped to the owner and was like hey
these rumors are ridiculous like I want
to be here just kind of everyone just
kind of went on um and I'm not sure that
Amy adamr for got that you know what I
mean so like I think when there was an
option of like maybe we should make a
move here's how we want things would you
agree with this and he was like I'm not
so sure I think then it became clear
like we need someone who was all in
going forward and like it it's time for
a new coach and obviously you say what
does this mean for New England I think
what it means is if if if if the
Patriots move on from belich there is a
really really good coach a proven good
head coach is a viable option Jim
Harbaugh's
options how many options do you think he
has in the
NFL I know he has some interest I know
he has some interest I also know in the
last two years yeah two years he's had
interest as well Vikings Broncos you
know I think had he come in and said
that he was definitely taking the
Broncos job I think he would have had a
good shot at it last year ultimately he
did
not you know lightning has to strike to
for a coach to get offered job it has to
be literally perfect so I can't say
right now I know for sure that Harbaugh
has a spot I know there is interest I
know when he has gone in the past into
these interviews he hasn't really viewed
them as interviews it's more been like I
am Jim Harbaugh uh I would like to see
the offer now like it's sort of like
that and maybe he's earned that you know
um but I would say at least there's
interest I don't know if there's going
to be an offer and I and I know there's
an offer on the table for m to stay that
he would be more than fine
with Chicago going to stay with Matty
Eber flu so right as we were going on
the reason I was a little late getting
to my zoom uh sources have said that the
Bears have fired offensive coordinator
Luke gy and Andrew janoko their
quarterback's coach that is obviously a
very significant move of the Chicago
Bears and you look at the development of
the quarterback you look at are they
going to have a new quarterback or not
like there's a lot there's a lot there
um that is a very significant move for
the bears but also if you're going to
fire the offensive coordinator generally
it's the head coach making the call
generally that means the head coach is
safe I had received indications that the
head coach was safe before the end of
the season those have not been firmed up
and no one has said like yes he is
definitely staying but you make a
significant offensive move generally
that indicates the coach is probably
sticking all right so the Bears have
fired their offensive
coordinator and their quarterback's
coach and their quarterback's coach okay
which leads you to believe they will do
what with the number one overall pick
given that
information I don't know I wish I knew
uh I would like to know the evaluations
of Drake May I'd like to know the
evaluations of kale Williams I'd like to
know the evaluations of you know whoever
else would figure into that spot and I
think that's really what this is it's
it's not did justtin Fields do well
enough to uh to stick around like he did
very well by the end of the year Justin
Fields look really good that's actually
not sort of what makes the decision what
makes the decision is I have these
evaluations of these quarterbacks who
are coming out of the draft how do I
compare that with what I've seen from
Justin fields on an NFL field plus the
contract that Justin Fields would be
getting plus you know compare that to
the cheaper contract rookie would be
getting plus the compensation you'd be
getting when you trade Fields it's all a
mathematical equation essentially but
the unknown is is how good is kale
Williams like some people think he's
momes very possible some people think he
is not it's also possible it's a biggest
decision that Ryan Poes will ever make
um and I don't think they're there yet
he see in Rapaport NFL Network National
Insider the uh insiders at 1 Eastern on
uh Monday through Friday on NFL Network
also Dolphins Chiefs that'll be Saturday
night on peacock exclusively where
weather is going to be an issue could
you
could you could you rank the openings
right now if we went with Carolina and
the Chargers in Washington Vegas
Atlanta you have you have one place
where you go that's the ideal place
that's where I'd start and ownership and
all of that and salary cap stuff you
know it's so hard I think there are such
they're not always good ones because a
lot of times if a team is terrible it's
not a good opening I would say if I
think the Chargers is really good
because you have the quarterback and
like you get there and now with that
comes expectations you're going to get
to the Chargers job with a really uh
star studded roster um you know you're
going to get there and you're going to
say you really need to win right um I
would say the Falcons have everything
but a quarterback so if you're confident
you can get a quarterback that's a
really good job Panthers would certainly
um you know Panthers would certainly
take some
time that's a good job if you believe in
the quarterback I would say what about
the
owner to me and this is just me I don't
really see an issue
there right like to me he is an owner
who wants to win very badly very very
badly intensely badly now that's
separate from the thing that happened in
the Jaguars game throwing a drink that
was bad that was bad but I'm just saying
as an owner
you know did he make a rash decision
with Frank Frank Reich
like I I don't know it was not working
it was real ugly it was not working um
so I don't to me like you have an owner
who's intensely committed to winning
that is okay even if sometimes it makes
people uncomfortable I like the
Washington job because you got the
second pick in the draft that's a great
fan base you can go in and you got new
ownership backing you what do you think
of
Washington um yeah I mean I definitely I
definitely like the Washington job um it
might take a minute you know I certainly
think it might take a minute um you need
a quarterback I think you're probably
going to get one with the number two
pick it's a harder build but and you
know then there's the other like there's
going to be the stadium things that are
going on there's the business side that
needs to be fixed there's a lot going on
there but it seems to me that the new
ownership group really gets it and has
proven they they get it you know what I
mean um and so I would say that's a
really good job it would just take a
little longer to be a really good job
what is the uh earliest time frame that
a coach can be
hired um iners interviews for those who
are currently employed can't begin until
the
22nd so if it's Jim Harbaugh and you
complete the the Dei requirements he
could be hired sooner that kind of gives
him a little bit of an advantage but
like these are all going to be a while
now Antonio Pierce could be hired a
little quicker you know they could do
two interviews with people of color who
are not currently employed and then just
hire Antonio Pierce um so I think
Harbaugh or Pierce could happen quicker
everything else is going to be like you
know around Championship weekend or
after or God like after after all that
you know but Antonio pierce the Raiders
still have to by the Rooney
Rule yes two coaches at least of color
who are not currently employed in the
building by the writers yes Ian canot
just promote him Ian thank you uh good
luck this weekend and we appreciate your
time all right thanks man enj Ian
Rapaport NFL Network Insider once again
you can watch the game exclusively on
peacock our home that'll be Saturday
night it's the Kansas City Chiefs Miami
Dolphins